[Applaudissements]
mes chers compatriotes
non sérieux vous vous êtes déjà demandé
ce que ça signifie ce mot compatriote
littéralement est étymologiquement
signifie ceux qui partagent la terre de
nos pères c'est bien moi quand on me dit
ça je pense à mon arbre généalogique et
mes pairs bah c'est un peu partout en
france et au maroc c'est en belgique en
allemagne au danemark
et encore je suis remonté qu'à trois
générations
donc mes compatriotes finalement si on
étudie bien vous comme moi je suis sûr
c'est la terre entière
je m'appelle guillaume achten je suis
votre compatriote est ce que je veux
vous dire ce soir c'est que j'ai envie
de vous aimez vraiment parce que je sais
je vous connais pas encore mais je sais
que vous êtes tous complètement
merveilleux j'ai cru que j'étais
moi-même merveilleux est en fait la vie
m'a appris que j'étais qu'une misérable
merveille mais je sais que vous êtes
tous complètement merveilleux parce que
vous avez tous quelque chose ça vous a
été dit ce soir vous avez tous quelque
chose d'unique
le talentueux et surtout vous avez
quelque chose que je n'ai pas chacun est
donc si je m'ouvre à vous si je prend le
large si je sors de moi même et si je
vous laisse rentrer en moi si je cherche
à vous comprendre comprendre voilà un
autre mot intéressant comprendre prendre
en soi accueillir l'autre est bien là je
vais vraiment m'enrichir et
éventuellement vous allez aussi vous
enrichir si vous prenez qui vous me
prenez un bon soir je m'appelle
guillemoles sten et je suis incapable de
vous dire d'où je viens
c'est vrai c'est une question qu'on se
pose souvent tu viens d'où ou est ce que
vous venez etc
alors moi je finis
à epernay un petit village en champagne
magnifique mais j'ai passé six mois et
après je suis parti vivre à bouffémont
en banlieue parisienne à orléans dans le
centre à auxerre en bourgogne à dijon en
bourgogne aussi en angleterre dans un
autre village en angleterre à lyon à
genève en suisse à vevey en suisse à
séville en andalousie espagne
et puis plus tard au pérou est
maintenant à paris donc d'où je viens
c'est un petit peu compliqué en revanche
qui je suis ça j'ai un petit peu plus
appris à aller le chercher à le savoir
parce que je suis donc sorti moi même
j'ai pris le large et je continue
j'espère et je suis allé voir d'autres
personnes je suis allé voir les autres
et je continue à les voir des gens
complètement différents
différent de moi est différente mon
milieu et c'est eux c'est vous tous qui
m'apprenait qui je suis qui me montrer
les talents que j'ai ce que gm peut
accepter ce que j'ai du mal à accepter
assumer ce que j'ai développé et c'est
vous aussi qui me montrer malgré ma
mauvaise volonté
les talents que je n'ai pas et ça c'est
vraiment important et ce n'était pas
évident pour moi parce que je suis issu
d'un milieu catholique traditionnelle
bourgeois j'étais dans les écoles où on
me disait vous êtes l'élite de la france
vous êtes responsable vous êtes j'étais
aux scouts et on disait le plus fort
protège le plus faible et vous
clairement vous êtes les plus forts très
bien cela dit j'ai appris énormément de
choses marié jeu scouts bon donc j'ai
fait mes études
sauf que à 19 ans j'étais marié père de
famille en même temps que l'étudiant
parce qu'il fallait faire encore plus
beau encore plus fort que l'élite de la
france est et je me suis demandé quand
même qu'est ce que j'allais faire de ma
vie
comment est ce que j'allais être
complètement merveilleux au milieu de
cette élite là qui mettait la pression
et je n'avais aucune idée mais ce que je
voulais en fait c'était être agriculteur
comme on prend comme mon grand-père mai
c'était pas franchement le premier au
programme et donc je me suis un petit
peu laissée portée est là et bien les
solutions me sont venues de l'extérieur
j'ai arrêté de me poser la question
qu'est ce que je vais faire de ma vie je
me suis dit je vais commencer par
découvrir et j'ai eu des profs
merveilleux prof de commerce
international
des profs de logistique des profs
d'entrepreneuriat et en écoutant les
différents profs les différents sujets
et en me promenant dans paris en voyant
devant les magasins de luxe parisiens là
que les files d'attentes de deux chinois
de japonais qui raffolent de nos
produits de luxe mais venu une idée
naturellement tout seul en conquête et
non tout ce que j'ai pu écouter en
allant par ci par là de créer un site
internet pour vendre des produits de
luxe pour les japonais aujourd'hui on
est en 2016 ça peut paraître
complètement anodin mais à l'époque on
était en 99 99 internet savait pas
encore explosé et finalement l'idée elle
a très très bien fonctionné parce que
les industriels français n'arrivait pas
à exporter au japon parce qu'il ya des
règles douanières très forte
or les japonais avaient une très forte
demande pour les produits français
donc avec internet eh ben on a pu vendre
etc soir c'est à dire que les japonais
virtuellement venez en france faisait
leur petit colis et je l'envoyer par la
poste et ça ça ça a explosé
bon mais une fois que c'était fait je me
suis rendu compte que ma qualité c'était
de d'innover en essayant d'aller par-ci
par-là de changer de bouger et de de me
laisser imprégner de plein d'idées
complètement différente de milieux
différents mais pas forcément de gérer
ça la vie m'a appris que la gestion du
quotidien c'est pas forcément mon fort
alors je suis parti sur autre chose
je suis allé voir les petites
entreprises en difficulté je vais les
écouter
je suis allé voir les grandes
entreprises de la finance je les
écoutais aussi de découvrir
je trouve ça passionnant mais j'ai
trouvé ça un petit peu injuste parce que
les grandes entreprises
elle avait des solutions de financement
fenomeno énorme notamment les marchés
publics et les petites entreprises
notamment en difficulté bas à rien
d'abord elle intéresse personne ou alors
si les intérêts des banquiers c'est très
très cher donc je me suis dit on va
faire comme les grandes entreprises mais
pour une multitude de petites
entreprises et là j'ai monté une société
de financement des entreprises en
difficulté
et petit on a rassemblé l'ensemble des
créances l'ensemble des stocks des
entreprises par internet et on a fait un
titre s'appelle la titrisation qu'on
vendait en bourse et ça a permis à des
entreprises en difficulté de se
développer d'avoir une meilleure
trésorerie
voilà j'ai continué comme ça en
associant des idées c'est à dire en
découvrant un problème et en 1 en allant
chercher des solutions dans des lieux
complètement différent et j'ai avancé
j'ai connu voilà comme vous l'avez dit
la gloire le succès la fortune fin tout
ce que vous voulez sauf que je n'étais
pas vraiment heureux parce qu'il
manquait l'essentiel parce qu'en fait
j'avais deux j'avais une vie
professionnelle où il fallait être
combatif compétitif gagner il fallait
être le meilleur
et puis j'avais une vie privée où
j'étais plutôt dans le social dans
l'humanitaire aider les plus faibles et
un moment donné c'est mon corps qui m'a
dit stop là faut arrêter
d'abord tu as atteint tous ses objectifs
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait après et puis
ça va pas de vivre de vie pas du tout en
parallèle donc mon corps m'a dit stop il
m'a arrêté quatre mois ça s'appelle une
hernie discale cervicale une opération
etc
et pendant ces quatre mois je me suis
dit mais qu'est ce qui est vraiment
important pour moi qu'est ce qui me rend
vraiment heureux
thomas d'aquin nous dit ce qui rend
l'homme heureux c'est de faire ce pour
quoi il est fait j'avais pas ce pourquoi
j'ai été fait mais je vais chercher
qu'est-ce qui m'ont heureux et là j'ai
trouvé ce pourquoi je suis fait et donc
j'ai choisi de quitter cette vie là de
quitter ce confort qui petit à petit
m'isole parce que plus on est conforme
on a besoin des autres mais on a besoin
de plus on est isolé plus on est isolé
moi on est heureux en tout cas moi c'est
comme ça et donc je suis parti à
l'opposé
à la rencontre des personnes à la rue en
vivant sans argent comme eux en amérique
du sud en europe pendant deux ans puis
deux ans en vivant avec l'équivalent du
rsa pour connaître tout parcours de
sortie de rue des personnes en situation
de grande précarité
et là j'ai été très étonné parce que moi
qui était le plus fort qui allaient à la
rencontre des plus faibles j'ai trouvé
des personnes très très riche très forte
et ce sont eux qui m'ont le plus
apporter véritablement ce sont eux qui
m'ont appris que finalement ce qu'on
apprend à l'école de manière très
théorique
ça nous sert énormément dans notre
quotidien sans qu'on s'en rende compte
iliad elmaleh nous parler du compas
qu'on n'utilise jamais dans la vie ben
moi je peux vous dire que apprendre à
poser un problème à prendre du recul a
essayé de se projeter de voir les
solutions à venir etc
ça nous fait gagner beaucoup plus de
temps que de se lancer tout de suite
comme on peut le faire en amérique du
sud par exemple et se planter et
recommencer sans avoir de recul
voilà je suis revenu en france après où
j'ai choisi de vivre dans des
colocations solidaires avec des
sans-abri et là je me suis rendu compte
que vraiment on est tous ce que j'écris
là deux misérables merveille c'est à
dire qu'on est tous merveilleux parce
qu'on a reçu nos talents nos compétences
mais avec ce qu'on en fait on est un peu
misérable aussi et puis il ya les
personnes comme moi qui ont appris à
montrer d'abord le nôtre côté
merveilleux et d'autres personnes ceux
avec qui je vis aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
plutôt appris leur côté misérables et
après à montrer leur côté misérables et
à force de faire des choses ensemble à
force de vivre ensemble finalement on se
rend compte qu'on est tous de misère à
merveille et qu'on a besoin les uns des
autres pour s'en sortir
voilà donc pour résumer ce que je
voudrais vous transmettre ce soir je
dois dire trois choses d'abord un
message personnel pour jean force pour
jean paul sartre pardon jean-paul le
bonheur c'est les autres
ça c'est fait
ensuite n'hésitez pas vraiment quand
vous avez un problème quand vous avez un
questionnement à prendre le large à
partir
physiquement et mentalement parce que
aussi les voyages intérieurs qui sont
très très forts dans l'objectif de
revenir à aller chercher loin
sans véritablement le chercher ce qui va
vous aider à résoudre votre problème
actuel et enfin dernière chose s'il vous
plaît vraiment ne considérait pas que
les personnes à la rue faible réfugiés
ce que vous voulez sont moins fortes -
bonne - utile que vous parce que
vraiment c'est pas le cas je vous en
supplie on est tous deux misérables
merveille et puisqu'on parlait de
scoutisme
je voudrais terminer sur un akin d'un
texte de rudyard kipling en vous disant
si tu es capable de reconnaître que
personne n'est au dessus de toi et que
personne n'est en dessous de toi et
qu'on a tous besoin les uns des autres
parce qu'on est tous deux misérables
merveille alors tu seras un homme mon
fils je remercie